so breaking tonight multiple people shot  on the northeast side of the valley all  unfolding right now near east cheyenne  and las vegas boulevard madison  kimbrough is joining us now live at that  location with the very latest madison  yeah this started as an argument between  two people it happened around three this  afternoon here at las brisas de cheyenne  apartments police say the fight  escalated into a shooting between both  people we can now confirm that four  people were taken to the hospital with  non-life-threatening injuries you can  see a heavy police presence here at  cheyenne and walnut very active scene  you can also see a lot of cars are  lining the street as police are  assessing the situation but good news  both lanes are now open here at cheyenne  and walnut so very easy access if you  are headed this direction reporting live  madison kimbrough live local now